bei einem sind sich wahrscheinlich alle
einig einen guten zeitpunkt für eine
pandemie gibt es nicht aber einen
besonders schlechten superwahljahr
nämlich denn da gibt es wie besonders
für die parteitaktik und wenn wir eines
gelernt haben in den letzten anderthalb
jahren dann virus plus parteitaktik
gleich hier geht es hier nicht nur um
parteitaktik sondern einfach um den
schutz der menschen ganz genau wie das
den start manche sagen fehlstart von
olaf scholz neue regierung geprägt hat
das zeichen wir nach in diesem video
teil 1 teil 2 ein ausblick wird jetzt
alles besser nach den jüngsten
beschlüssen bei der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und der
dort ja zelebrierten geschlossenheit die
man danach gezeigt hat kleiner spoiler
von einer die es wissen muss nach der
wahl ist vor der wahl merkel geht ampel
kommt corona bleibt
[Applaus]
im wahlkampf im sommer war corona kein
großes thema weil fallzahlen niedrig
viele leute waren genervt von dem thema
wahrheit kein gewinnerthema deswegen
blieben dann aber viele debatten geführt
die jetzt hektisch nachgeholt werden zum
beispiel 3g am arbeitsplatz zum beispiel
lockdown verunglimpfte zum beispiel
impfpflicht in altenheim ja das wird
jetzt debattiert wo die vierte welle
durch viele altenheime schon durch
gerollt ist thema wird gewinner dann so
richtig erst wieder nach der wahl und da
kam das parteitaktische dann so richtig
mit voller wucht ins spiel denn die
ampel die wollte gleich zu beginn signal
setzen fest steht für uns und das sage
ich auch sehr deutlich schulschließungen
lockt downs und ausgangssperren wird es
jedenfalls mit uns nicht mehr geben wir
werden jetzt einen überschaubaren
katalog wenig eingriffs intensiver
maßnahmen zur verfügung stellen die
ampel funktioniert auch bevor es sie
gibt also die ampel wollte die
sogenannte epidemische notlage von
nationaler tragweite
auslaufen lassen weil diese so genannte
notlage der exekutive also den
regierungen von bund und ländern
besonders weitreichende befugnisse gibt
bei der pandemie bekämpfung die ampel
hat jetzt gesagt das holen wir zurück in
die parlamente ist jetzt prinzipiell
auch keine so gute idee in einer
parlamentarischen demokratie die wir
haben aber die ampel hatte maximal
bescheidenes timing denn just zu dem
zeitpunkt wo sie die notlage auslaufen
lassen wollte wie es hieß begann sich
die vierte welle aufzutürmen und dann
ging es los
[Musik]
die ampel parteien die wollten partout
an ihrem plan festhalten weil
zurückrudern dass er ja nach fehlstart
aus und da klangen die grünen dann
manchmal wie die fdp auf die das ganze
zurückging ich finde es nicht sinnvoll
dass wir uns hier hinstellen und sagen
wir machen beim maßnahme die werden den
gerichten wieder gekippt von den
gerichten getippt mit einer sehr
ähnlichen begründung hatte der da noch
gesundheitsministerien sparen im grunde
genau dasselbe gefordert nämlich die
notlage auslaufen zu lassen interessant
jetzt die reaktion seiner partei der
union die gab sich nun sehr erzürnt
darüber dass die notlage auslaufen soll
das sei ein falsches signal
beziehungsweise das völlig falsche
signal nicht zu sagen es wird ein in
jeder hinsicht fatales signal an die
bevölkerung gegeben oder um es
zusammenzufassen was völlig abschotten
ende eine epidemische lage auszurufen
völlig absurd weil hier geht es hier
nicht mehr um parteitaktik sondern
einfach um den schutz der menschen eben
und deswegen gucken wir uns die ganze
sache jetzt mal ein bisschen genauer an
das fatale an dem signal sei so die
kritiker zweierlei zum einen eben die
falsche signalwirkung nach dem motto die
prekäre lage ist vorbei und zweitens
dass die besonders betroffenen länder
wie zum beispiel bayern ja nicht mehr
alle instrumente der pandemie bekämpfung
zur verfügung hätten weil aus diesem
berühmten instrumentenkasten einzelne
dieser instrumente rausgenommen werden
und tatsächlich war es auch so dass hat
die ampel gemacht immerhin kleiner trost
es gab einen kompromiss die instrumente
die wegfallen die frist dafür die wohl
noch mal ein bisschen verlängert von
ende november bis mitte dezember
vorausgesetzt diese instrumente haben
schon gegolten ende november aber davon
wird man ja ausgehen in den besonders
stark betroffenen bundesländern außerdem
bräuchte man sich ja sonst nicht darüber
beklagen dass eben diese instrumente
wegfallen wenn man sie gar nicht
einsetzt gehen wir die einzelnen
instrumente also nochmal durch bleiben
gern beim beispiel bayern denn auch da
ging es ja zur erinnerung ein
sonnenschutz der menschen also gucken
wir mal welche der maßnahmen welche der
instrumente die welt zu fallen drohten
haben denn dann schon gegolten ende
november zum stichtag in bayern als die
infektionszahlen daher schon ziemlich
hoch waren instrument 1 flächendeckende
ausgangssperren gab es die
wie war es denn mit flächendeckenden
schließung von kitas und schulen
die waren jetzt nirgendwo populär die
wollte niemand aber wie war es denn mit
der vorsorglichen flächendeckenden
schließung von gastronomie die ganze
sicher oder
und vom einzelhandel
verbot von gottesdiensten und
versammlungen
von reisen und
übernachtungsmöglichkeiten
jetzt sagt denn verstehe ich den ganzen
protest der unionsländer aber nicht so
richtig wenn ich mal sagen ist auch
nicht so leicht zu verstehen es sei denn
man versteht diesen move jetzt eben auch
als parteitaktisch motiviert auf der
anderen seite der ampel führte diese
logik dann allerdings auch zu der einen
oder anderen argumentativen verrenkung
den schultern überlasteten
intensivstationen wird am ende natürlich
auch keiner sein sie können jetzt sehr
drastische maßnahmen ergreifen auch in
sachsen auch in bayern wir sind auf sie
zugegangen und haben gesagt solche
maßnahmen haben einen längeren übergang
bis über den dritten advent hinaus dann
muss es aber jetzt auch gemacht werden
meine damen und herren wenn ihr das
jetzt so verstanden habt jetzt würde
frau göring-eckardt dafür werben noch
schnell die maßnahmen einzusetzen die
ihre partei dann mit abschafft dann habt
ihr es fürchte ich richtig verstanden
[Musik]
text bild schere nennen wir beim
fernsehen wenn das was wir hören nicht
passt zu dem was wir sehen und davon
gibt es eine reihe von beispielen zum
beispiel er hier hendrik wüst neuer
ministerpräsident von
nordrhein-westfalen nachfolger von armin
laschet der hat damit gedroht das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz der ampel mit
ebendiesem ausgedünnten
instrumentenkasten zu blockieren mit
einem veto im bundesrat weil eben ein
falsches signal stichwort falsches
signal genau das hat er gesagt wenige
tage nachdem er das hier in seinem
bundesland noch ziemlich okay fand und
weitere acht tage später fand dann das
hier in seinem bundesland statt perfekt
dazu nicht alles was an dem nachmittag
dort auf der anzeigetafel zu lesen war
fand ich witzig bin ja perfekt die haben
eine 4 1 klatsche bekommen aber über
eine sache muss ich doch ein bisschen
schwund spenden
und der wird sich einer im stadion
vermutlich gedacht haben was machen
diese menschen das war der rückweg
schauen wir nach vorn
gab also jetzt ja wieder so eine mpk
ministerpräsidenten konferenz im
kanzleramt ihr fragt euch jetzt
vielleicht wieso eigentlich genau damit
wollte die ampel doch eigentlich schluss
machen mit diesen exekutiven zocken im
kanzleramt mit der sogenannten re
parlamentarisierung offensive doch
wollte sie aber der politische druck
wurde daneben offenbar doch zu groß also
hat man sich wieder getroffen im
kanzleramt und genau dort soll sie jetzt
und ob auch noch neuen krisenstab geben
geleitet von einem general ob unter dem
alles besser wird ob da das
parteitaktische dann keine zentrale
rolle mehr spielen wird langfristig ob
also alle an einem strang ziehen und es
sogar noch in die selbe richtung werden
wir sehen müssen immerhin nach dieser
mpk war der erste eindruck ganz gut
demonstrative geschlossenheit
sie sehen an den beschlüssen dass wir
verstanden haben dass die lage sehr
ernst ist und ich bin froh dass in
dieser schwierigen lage
der schulterschluss funktioniert dass
die parteipolitik in den hintergrund
tritt dass wir schneller boostern und da
glaube ich kommen wir seit gestern
endlich voran und umso wichtiger ist es
dass ich jetzt bund und länder zusammen
getan haben solche geschlossenheit
zwischen cdu und den ampel parteien die
gab es tatsächlich selten oder ich würde
sogar sagen noch nie in der pandemie
bekämpfung die entscheidende frage ist
jetzt allerdings wie nachhaltig ist
diese geschlossenheit diese
ernsthaftigkeit eine sache die dafür
sprechen könnte dass die ampel parteien
also spd grüne und fdp schon gewissen
hebel auf die landesregierung haben weil
in allen landesregierungen mindestens
eine der ampel parteien also die spd die
grünen oder und oder die fdp drin sitzen
in allen 16 bundesländern
und bis auf eines weswegen hier in
berlin viele bei den ampel parteien aber
auch bei der cdu davon ausgehend bzw
befürchten dass es auch künftig aus
bayern bei der pandemie bekämpfung sehr
viele familien freundlich formuliert
gute ratschläge geben wird und pünktlich
zur mpk gab es auch wieder ein bei der
mpk sitzt markus söder jetzt nicht mehr
in der ersten reihe mit dabei vielleicht
auch deshalb gab es deswegen schon mal
vorab
medien einen vorschlag und zwar hier zur
impfpflicht ab 12 generell wäre es
natürlich gut wenn die impfpflicht
zumindest bei denen bei denen der
impfstoff schon nach produkt ist ab 12
auch stattfinden würde könnte man den
eindruck gewinnen sie hier nicht ganz
unrecht nach der wahl ist vor der wahl
genau und deswegen ist die frage wird
das parteitaktische tatsächlich auf
dauer zur seite gedrängt guck mal auf
bayern da ist 2023 landtagswahl und auch
wenn das also noch ein bisschen weg ist
kann man davon ausgehen die csu wird das
mindestens schon im hinterkopf haben
weil deren besondere rolle im
parteienspektrum in deutschland gründet
darauf dass sie in bayern über
jahrzehnte der überragende ergebnisse
hatte und wenn sie da mit 31 prozent
herumdümpelt wird das natürlich nicht
beizubehalten sein und nächstes jahr
sind schon vier andere landtagswahlen in
deutschland zunächst im märz im saarland
dann im mai in schleswig-holstein und
nordrhein-westfalen und dann im oktober
in niedersachsen spätestens dann werden
wir wissen ob man gelernt hat aus dem
superwahljahr 20 21 oder ob die pandemie
bekämpfung dann nächstes jahr wieder
überlagert wird von parteitaktik
[Musik]
also wird jetzt alles besser unter der
ampel bei der pandemie bekämpfung hängt
maßgeblich von zwei dingen ab erstens
wie entschlossen und frühzeitig die
bundesländer jetzt die maßnahmen
ergreifen die notwendig sind und
zweitens wie lange die disziplin anhält
bei allen beteiligten akteuren aller
parteien wie lange sie die pandemie
bekämpfung tatsächlich an 1 stellen vor
parteitaktischen erwägungen was glaubt
ihr was euro prognose war das jetzt der
game changer wird die ampel warten oder
bleibt das inoffizielle maskottchen der
deutschen pandemie politik
ja
und nicht vergessen
abonniert uns